le millésime 83 est arrivé il ne s'agit
pas de champagne mais d'un autre produit
bien français qui coûte beaucoup plus
cher
la haute couture les collections
commence à paris dans la traditionnelle
l'effervescence des acheteurs des
copieurs des journalistes et des
photographes de superbe créature vêtue
dévoile les trouvailles des créateurs
france franche jacques aubertin à verdun
puissesseau ont choisi de nous faire
admirer les collections avec l'oeil du
profane
la voilà elle est arrivée là moi de
divers sur un skateboard et en body
stocking de laine par 38 à londres je
préfère ne pas dire combien ensoleillé
ce beauty stocking et pour court n 1 bat
pour le corps à condition bien sûr que
le corps le supportent et que le body
n'est pas trop pas supporté
avec une veste en vinyle la voilà équipé
pour noël pensent les patineurs qui eux
n'ont pas besoin de glace sauf dans leur
verre
pendant qu'ils se trompent les pieds
dans l'eau ça ne les dérange pas
vraiment que des demoiselles portent
quelques kilos de fourrure sur des
justaucorps de l'aisne tels que les a
vus frédéric castets pour dior fourrure
sur des bancs dans des bosquets des
demoiselles venues de norvège ou du
kenya exalte devant les caméras la mode
de paris pour deux mille francs l'heure
ils peuvent accepter ce genre de pique
nique en forme de strip tease en tee
shirt humide et en short touristique
on apprend dans la rue sur la haute
couture autant que les ambassadrices et
princesses qui voit défiler dans des
salons dorés et 50 millions de robes ans
un jour ici c'est plus démocratique et
on en prime ces grands oubliés les
cameramen qui mêlent l'utile à
l'agréable vous habiter chez vos parents
je connais un bistrot sympa glisse entre
deux plants tintin et nanard aubertin et
puissesseau pour les dames aux ingrid et
autres sabrina
à part ça boulot boulot grâce à eux on
sera partout que l'hiver prochain la
femme sera toujours la femme bien sûr
mais aura la taille mince si elle peut
cardin exige des manteaux très large
austérité oblige jean patou qu'elle
verra la vie en noir avec hanae mori
givenchy ou paco rabanne
ou un rouge rouge vermillon et lapidus
réuni rouge rayé vu par lepage rouge bon
genre puisque chamelle
et rouge gala signé ferron
les jupes seront asymétrique venait
sauf on le british look a nous les
petites écossaise nougaro
de chérir
de la roche enfin sur les têtes des
chapeaux de roue ce qui prouveront com
ou scotia femme peut être le de l'homme
franchement mais ces dames ne sont
peut-être ont parcouru ni the gens dont
c'est encore tout à l'âge mais ni de
cette nuit ils vont arriver